[Musik]
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen heute zu einer weiteren
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 in
der letzten episode so werde hier
stehengeblieben wir haben dieses
häuschen hier gebaut und ich habe dort
hinten den süßen kleinen hügel entdeckt
mit dem
zwei bären drauf
die müssen wir dann gleich auf jeden
fall noch töten die sache ist allerdings
dass ich ja bereits in der letzten
episode so ein bisschen angedeutet habe
dass ich da etwas rein bauen möchte und
da wurde sogar ein bisschen in den
kommentaren rom spekuliert und der ein
oder andere hat sollen erraten wie zum
beispiel dieser user hier der meinte da
eine hobbit höhle hat war richtig geil
und das habe ich heute auch vor meine
lieben freunde hier kommt nämlich mein
neues haus rein einer robert oehle
dementsprechend werde ich dieses
häuschen was ich gebaut habe so ein
bisschen als lagerraum nutzen denke ich
mal jedoch muss ich mich jetzt erst mal
kurz um die bären kümmern die
allerdings gar nichts machen
[Musik]
dann kann es sein dass sie mich nur
angreifen
wenn ich denen gegenüber aggressiv werde
ist aber auch egal denn wir müssen uns
erst wenn hier vorne um den berg so ein
bisschen kümmern denn wir müssen hier so
viel erde abbauen bis wir eine 5 blog
hohe fläche haben
so wir haben hier vorne jetzt auf jeden
fall so viel vom berg abgetragen sodass
wir eine
12345 blog hohe fläche haben hier sogar
noch ein bisschen höher die bären tun
uns wirklich nichts entstehen hier
einfach und ich gelesen
[Musik]
da kommt ja auch noch was vor dass wir
heute bauen werden wir werden damit zwar
heute nicht fertig war das wirklich eine
menge arbeit sein wird die sache ist
allerdings dass sich auf jeden fall den
start heute machen möchte und dafür
müssen wir auch erst mit unserer erde
nehmen und hier den ganzen bereich ein
bisschen zukleistern
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir hier vorne auf jeden
fall alles zugebaut der berg haben uns
ein paar mal gefährlich nah hat
allerdings schlussendlich nichts gemacht
das ist auch sehr gut denn wir müssen
auf hilfe am leben bleiben wir haben
einiges zu tun vor heute das nächste was
ich nämlich machen muss ist endlich mal
wieder einige fichtenholz bäume ecke
halt einfach fichten abbauen ich weiß
auch gar nicht ob ich gesagt habe
endlich mal wieder weil wir das auch in
der letzten folge schon getan haben habe
ich die halt einfach fichtenholz die
sache ist auch meine lieben freunde das
sehe ich jetzt erstmal ganz kurz während
ich ein paar bäume abfälle ich habe mir
dafür extra noch zwei neue exe gemacht
die sache ist dass und das wird der eine
oder andere mitbekommen haben der sich
nicht nur die mannschaft folgen dann
guckt sondern auch die anderen videos
hier auf einem kanal ich habe gestern
vorgestern sorry vorgestern wollte ich
eigentlich bereits ein video hochladen
wo ich das hier mache wo ich diese hobby
tödliche bauer das habe ich auch
aufgenommen die sache ist allerdings
dass sich bei dem gameplay nicht auf den
start der aufnahme geklickt habe ich
habe quasi einfach minecraft gespielt
und nehmen kann meine pace käme um einen
ton also mein mikrofon aufgenommen und
das macht natürlich keinen sinn deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme einen
backup denn immer bevor ich eine
aufnahme sparte mache ich einen backup
meiner welt und dann nehme ich einfach
dieses backup und löschte das was im
video gemacht habe die anderthalb
stunden waren quasi komplett umsonst und
mach es einfach noch mal neu deswegen
das ist für mich gerade auch ziemlich
easy hier vorzugehen ich weiß direkt wo
noch mal die fichten waren ich werde
auch gleich genau wissen wo ich meine
rosensträucher kriege das ist jetzt
quasi in einer gewissen form cheating
dass ich mir vorher alles angeguckt habe
aber glaubt mir am liebsten hätte ich
das nicht so gemacht und hätte einfach
die folge genommen weil die echt cool
war ich habe im orca entdeckt also
irgend so eine neue art fische oder wale
die wir vorher noch nicht gesehen haben
ich habe wieder zurückgelaufen zu meiner
alten ersten base zu meinen keller base
da muss ich nämlich gleich auch noch mal
hin zurück weil ich nur dort tatsächlich
bieten hatte also birken setzlinge denn
die benötige ich auch für meine hobbys
höhle
nur dort habe ich beispielsweise auch
rosensträucher bekommen und ja wie
gesagt das problem war halt dass ich
dachte die aufnahme nicht gestartet habe
dann habe ich halt vorgestern auf einem
kanal einfach ein kurzes entschuldigungs
video hochgeladen die meisten von euch
haben sie auch wirklich verstanden ein
paar waren ein bisschen beleidigt kann
ich auch verstehen wenn ich eine serie
gucke auf netflix amazon prime der song
irgendwo keine ahnung hat wo dann würde
ich mich auch ärgern wenn gesagt werde
dass kommt am 10 zehnten raus und dann
kommt es am 15 weil der regisseur
verkappter schauspieler krank geworden
ist ich glaub ich will auch so also ich
kann alle seiten verstehen
schlussendlich habe ich allerdings kein
riesiges produktionsbüro irgendwie
hinter mir schön warum fällt der baum
sondern macht hat hier ganz allein und
ich hoffe ihr versteht das und ich will
euch jetzt auch gar nicht mehr lange
hier zu texten es gibt eine menge sachen
die ich mir hier wirklich holen muss für
die heutige folge ich habe mir wieder
eine riesen to do liste und wir werden
es auch gar nicht heute schaffen die
hobbit höhere fertig zu bauen allerdings
so die groben umrisse des wegen euch
erst mal ganz kurz eine lange time lab
cent berechnen müssen benötigen
film ab
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich bin jetzt
gerade hier vorne mal zurückgefahren in
den ort beziehungsweise in die region wo
ich ja in etwa gespannt bin ich habe da
hinten ja mainz bonn punkt gehabt mit
dem krokodil im sumpf und hier fordern
wir dann dieses an blumen bio nie
gefunden allerdings sind wir auch schon
direkt richtig denn ich benötige vier
rosensträucher das sind ja die hier
glaube ich schaue mal ganz kurz ja
rosenstrauch das andere war moan also
dass hier noch das hier und den hier
auch dann habe ich acht rosensträucher
ok perfekt das reicht auf jeden fall aus
jetzt benötige ich auf jeden fall auch
noch einiges an samen denn vor meinen
eine kleine hobbit höhle kommt ein
kleines feld nicht weil ich unbedingt
mit denke da könnte ich perfekt sachen
anbauen und weizen keine ahnung was ich
will mich ja ein bisschen mehr auf
kartoffeln konzentrieren und so ein
generell riesiges feld werde ich ihn
noch mal demnächst bauen allerdings so
ein bisschen aus deko zwecken
30 stück habe ich mir jetzt einfach mal
geholt die sollten auch perfekt
ausreichen nun muss ich hier auf jeden
fall auch noch ein bisschen greve
laboren benutze ich mal wieder meine
altbewährte fackel hinsetzt taktik
nämlich einfach eine fackel runter
setzte der ganze krempel fällt auf die
fackel drauf wo ich bekomme direkt eine
menge gremmel zugeordnet in revel
benötige ich nämlich nicht wenn man eine
hülle sondern zum weiterverwerten für
grobe erde denn es gibt ja zwei
verschiedene arten von er das gibt
einmal das hier und es gibt das hier das
hier ist ja ganz normales gras und ganz
normale erde also dass hier wird zu ganz
normal im gras wenn es mit gras
verbunden ist wenn nicht drauf scheint
keine ahnung was noch bei alles zu zählt
und damit das zu gras wird die sache ist
allerdings dass ich für meinen weg in
der hobbit höhle so ein bisschen alle
möglichen materialien verwenden möchte
wie beispielsweise gruppe erde ich
möchte ein privat verwenden ich möchte
bruchsteine verwenden bemooste steine
deswegen das ist jetzt los
das sollte allerdings auch schon 1
travel ausreicht meine lieben freunde
und jetzt kümmern wir uns direkt mal um
einen laut dafür benötige ich nämlich
genau das hier das ist
eichenlaub perfekt eichenlaub benötige
ich insgesamt wo habe ich es entstehen
hier auf meiner liste 17 stück die habe
ich direkt jetzt schon bekommen den
eichen stamme nämlich auch noch mal kurz
wieder mit und jetzt können wir es auch
direkt mal eben rüber bewegen zu meiner
da ist wieder die dummen
wir können uns direkt über bewegen zu
meiner start-ups meine lieben freunde zu
meiner kleinen keller base ich bin ganz
ehrlich hier vorne die sonnenblumen muss
sich auch noch mitnehmen ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich vermisse das ja schon so ein
bisschen ich fand dass sie auch sehr
schön mit diesem ganzen wir haben eine
riesige fläche hier hat man einiges
bauen wir haben jede lager gehabt
eine ahnung warum hier am helllichten
tag auf einer normalen höhle
höhle sondern höhe plötzlich lava chillt
aber gut wir konzentrieren uns hier erst
mal auf unser projekt die hobbit höhle
ich war ja gerade bayern reden dass ich
das hier vorne schon so ein bisschen
vermisse ich finde sie einfach unfassbar
schön mit den ganzen blumen und so das
sieht schon cool aus hier von denen
brauche ich jetzt erstmal ganz gut für
meine rolle wie beispielsweise auch
diese sonnenblumen hier die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mir dann auch
gedacht habe und das wird ja auch einige
mal in die kommentare geschrieben dass
ich mir einfach ein paar portale bauen
kann generell ist es in dieser staffel
minecraft mit luca ja auch so im
vergleich in bzw im gegensatz zur ersten
staffel minecraft mit luca dass ich hier
so ein bisschen mods installiert habe
wie beispielsweise oben links die
minimap
oder generell die ganzen neuen biome
oder die tri top modifikation und
deswegen habe ich mir vielleicht auch
gedacht dass ich das ganze auch mal mit
einer portal modifikation probieren
sollte da bin ich allerdings happig
angewiesen dazu schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare
ob ihr das als schiiten betrachtet ob
ihr sagt das ist okay wenn ich mir
beispielsweise hier dann in meiner welt
irgendwie portale setzen könnte um
einfach schnurstracks vom beispielsweise
hier dann gehe ich irgendwie hier rein
zack und kommt hinten bei meinem dorf
raus was haltet ihr von schnäpsen und in
die kommentare ich bin total da das also
das dürft komplettieren scheiden diese
fünf weizen können nehme ich mir jetzt
noch mal mit und die birken setzlinge
die beliebten stämme habe ich mir schon
eingepackt sonst haben wir hier nicht
mehr viel werden noch ein paar eisen
klumpen alle diese sachen hier kann ich
mir auch zu hause ein fachkräften und
diese sachen hier brauchen wir erst
recht nicht ich nehme doch mal ein
bisschen mehr erde mit ich habe sogar
schon so ein paar stücke extra hier
gelassen ich habe allerdings wirklich
mit dieser trip modifikation so
unfassbar viele möglichkeiten was holz
angeht und den rüstungs ständer benötige
ich eigentlich auch um einer horde die
sache ist allerdings dass ich auch den
gerne hier stehen lassen möchte weil
wenn wir uns dann portale bauen will ich
nicht hin zurückkehren und dann
ist ja alles irgendwie abgerutscht da
müssen wir noch mal hinten ins
hexenhäuschen rein dass wir so ein
stinkendes paul ii die sache ist
allerdings dass ich jetzt immer noch nur
einen teil meiner sachen mir bisher
gekostet habe deswegen euch auch ihr
jetzt auch mal eine ganz kurze time netz
wie ich mir den rest hole für die hobby
töne
[Musik]
ich habe hier vorne gerade alle sachen
vorbereitet so sieht das jetzt erst mal
aus diese ganzen dinge brauchen wir
erstmal nur für das heutige video ich
weiß nicht ob dies in zwei folgen
schaffen werden mit der hobbit höhle
allerdings auf jeden fall in höchstens
drei folgen deswegen konzentrieren uns
jetzt erstmal auf den äußeren bereich
dafür benötigen wir fichtenholz stufen
fichtenholz zäune ein fichtenholz autor
und das sollte glaube ich auch erst mal
ausreichen wir müssen jetzt erstmal die
mitte finden ich denke mal das wird in
etwa hier sein dieser block und dort
bauen wir das ganze jetzt wie folgt sagt
zack zack zack zack und darüber auch
die kann sogar da bleiben allerdings
muss ich gucken dass ich hier vorne
treffe perfekt also baue das ganze jetzt
erst mal so zwei blöcke übereinander von
diesen fichtenholz stufen und ein davor
so als abdach so dass wir drunter 1 2 3
und 1 halben blog also dreieinhalb löcke
platz haben nun müssen wir zur linken
seite rein runtergehen 1 2 und auch zur
rechten seite einen halb blog
runtergehen und dann auch wieder das ab
dach drauf bauen genau das gleiche
wiederholen wir jetzt wieder auf beiden
seiten wieder quasi einhalten blog
runter und zwei zur seite zack zack und
nun machen wir das auf jeder seite
nummer 51 schritte also
12345 und dann auch wieder überall so
ein kleines abdach beziehungsweise also
eine kleine treppe und das wiederholen
wir jetzt auch hier auf der linken seite
eins zwei drei vier und fünf und jetzt
auch wieder das kleine ab dachte daran
was wir nun machen ist dass wir alle
blöcke die man von vorne sieht nun
erstmal entfernen
denn
wir haben
glaube ich
eine höhle
dann demnächst unter unserer hobbit
kühle wir entfernen auf jeden fall alle
blöcke die man hier ihnen gesehen könnte
hier oben auf da geht's auch wieder rein
[Musik]
geht's
runter
und auch auf der minimap oben sehen wir
dass dort drunten und wirklich nicht
ganz so klein das frühere system ist die
sache ist allerdings dass wir uns darauf
erstmal gar nicht konzentrieren wollen
denn hier kann man uns heute hier um die
hobbit höhle deswegen werde ich auch das
thema eben ganz kurz wieder abbauen hier
vorne zeigt wenn wir müssen hier auf
jeden fall später so ein bisschen
reingehen und wir gehen jetzt auch die
rechts an der seite ein bisschen entlang
so dass wir alle blöcke abbauen die man
wirklich sehen könnte denn das soll
natürlich nachher nicht so hoch war
rumpelt aussehen von außen klar so das
ganze seinen rustikalen look kam auch
von innen aber jetzt nicht so mit
steinen und mit werde und keine ahnung
hat so soll das auf jeden fall von
fordert erst mal aussehen so ein
bisschen clean und jetzt spüren wir den
bereich herum so ein bisschen abnehmen
darf unsere fichtenholz sonne gehen 1 2
3 4 5 nach vorne einen kleinen schlenker
und dann 12 34 1 2 3 4 und nochmal 1234
jetzt sind wir genau in der mitte
angekommen hat hier das licht sound und
jetzt wieder 1 2 3 4 1 nach vorne 23 4 1
nach vorne 234 jetzt wieder den kleinen
schlenker und dann können wir die
letzten vier fichtenholz zu nehmen um 12
34 wieder hier zu setzen das hier ist
noch ein bisschen der abgesperrte
bereich und in diesem abgesperrten
bereich wird unser feld stattfinden hier
vorne kommen parcours bis hin und hier
vorne einfach besser deswegen habe ich
hier gerade erst mal diese ganze unkraut
kram sie entfernt und bevor wir jetzt
die den außenbereich auch fertig machen
mit den kürbissen hier mit den fässern
hier mit dem feld und hier dem feld mit
dem trampelpfad wir es jetzt erst mal um
das dass sie ein bisschen schöner
aussieht dafür nehmen wir nämlich
unseren sandstein und setzten hier
sandstein nach unten das war einer
zuviel und hier vorne auf der seite auch
ich hoffe mal dass ich jetzt überhaupt
genügend sandstein habe denn mehr habe
ich gerade gar nicht
[Musik]
ich hab den bruch weit und breit
entsandt
davon lassen wir uns vorher ist gar
nicht mal beirren darum kümmere ich mich
gleich ich gleich jetzt erstmal alles
mit dem glatten sandstein aus bis auf
diese beiden seiten hier denn hier
kommen eichenholz fall turn reinen das
sind so ein bisschen die rollläden klar
dahinter ist gerade so ein bisschen erde
das ist nicht ganz so schön ich habe
auch nicht genügend klappen sandstein
in solchen momenten wünscht man sich
dass man in der wüste gesponnen wer ist
uns aber jetzt gerade auch erst mal egal
ich plötzlich hier erst mal so ein
bisschen bietenholz dransetzen dass er
jetzt
irgendwie
würde man eigentlich vermuten dass
dadurch dass ich dieses video so halb
schon vorgestern aufgenommen habe dass
das jetzt alles ein bisschen besser
klappen sollte aber irgendwie klappt
hier nur schlechter
na ja das wird auf jeden fall der
eingang sein und den kreis wenn wir
jetzt aus hier mit einer fichtenholz
treppe dann auch hier da kommt
eigentlich auch noch sandstein hätte ich
mach jetzt erst mal provisorisch er da
dran denn hier kommt auch noch eine
fichtenholz treppe hin dann kommt hier
vorne auch noch eine fichtenholz treppe
hinab und hier unten auch und hier an
die seiten kommen nun fichtenholz
falltür fichtenholz falltür hier oben
auch hin die bleibt da noch so und hier
unten kommt auch eine hin dass sie wird
an der eingang ist ein bisschen blöd aus
wie ich ganz ehrlich der erde hier und
im ganzen kreis allerdings
wenn wir sind hätten wird es ganz gut
aus ich wohl jetzt auf sand scheiß auf
wieso sollen wir denn warten kopf ganze
band hole
[Musik]
freunde ich habe gerade mal 1 fast 26
sand geholt und hier vorne sind auch
schon ein paar reichen gewachsen hier
vornehmlich eine da und da und hier auch
schon bier kennen nämlich hier dort hier
vorne sonst noch nicht gewachsen
allerdings ist das ein bisschen auch
mein ziel alle möglichen bäume einfach
hierhin holen so dass immer wenn wir von
einem gewissen baum dessen was brauchen
das
habe das sicher dann direkt stehen also
ich nehme jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
meinen sand und verkraftet dass hier
alles in sandstein jetzt haben nämlich
erst mal so viele wie wir auf jeden fall
erstmal benötigen um hier den boden
fertig zu machen auch hier die ecke und
hier oben den bereich den rest kann ich
jetzt von den sandsteinen die ich habe
genauso wie die ich hier vorne zack
geben fix
hinschmeißen und dass diese ganz einfach
zu glatten sandsteinen werden den
restlichen sand packe ich jetzt erst mal
hier rein die sache ist dass ich da oben
auch noch mal ganz kurz ein verrottetes
fleisch reinpacken könnte und hier
keineswegs den glatten sandstein dem
werde ich das gleich mal daran
platzieren wenn er fertig ist es macht
jetzt keinen sinn kurz zu warten da kann
man die zeit lieber nutzen um erstmal
den außenbereich ein bisschen fertig zu
machen denn dafür benötigen wir jetzt
erstmal unsere kürbisse dann natürlich
selbstverständlich auch einen
wassereimer
den ich jetzt gerade erst mal mir auch
holen muss dafür gehen jetzt allerdings
einfach mal hier vorne unser dorf rhein
wo die beiden herren whirlpool entspannt
genießen und gönnen uns hier zwei wasser
einmal raus wir haben uns generell
dieses dorf hier noch gehalt mal so
richtig angeschaut wir sind noch einmal
in die häuser rein gegangen oder haben
uns irgendwie kisten angeschaut
geschweige denn haben wir irgendwie mit
den dorfbewohnern gehandelt das wird
allerdings alles noch kommen ich möchte
generell in dieser minecraft mit lukas
staffel 2 das projekt nicht 100 folgen
lang haben sondern nur 50 folgen weil
ich gemerkt habe dass es in minecraft
mit luca staffel 1 sich irgendwie ein
bisschen gezogen hat und deswegen möchte
ich auch dieses mal früher schon ins
ende gehen früher in den neckar
allerdings soll es jetzt erstmal diese
kürbisse hier gehen die können wir
nämlich hier einfach irgendwie
hinstellen nun nehme ich mir für da
vorne auch noch direkt hier ein fass mit
damit habe ich davon habe ich mir nicht
22 stück gemacht 21 stück gemacht und
paar zu viele ihr könnt mich allerdings
1 hinsetzen das soll allerdings
zu einer seite zeigen und dann müssten
wir uns jetzt auch direkt nochmal einige
laternen machen denn vier laternen
brauche ich tatsächlich minimum also
nehmen wir jetzt erstmal unseren reisen
blog können uns hier von ein bisschen
eisen wieder rausziehen können
eigentlich auch mal direkt zerstören das
total unnötig dass mir die recht gemacht
habe und jetzt machen wir nicht das war
auch wieder falsch wird packen
tatsächlich einfach so hier rein kriegen
dadurch die eisen klumpen packen die
hier in den kreis und dann in die mitte
vier fackeln reise fünfter können uns
auch direkt fünf laternen machen in
großhadern eisen pack ich jetzt hier
wieder rein meine laterne bzw fackeln
habe ich ja immer auf der 2 deswegen
kommen die auch da wieder hin türen auf
kann auch einfach offen bleiben tag der
offenen tür hier mal bei mir und jetzt
ich weiß immer noch nicht so richtig ob
der uns magna
der macht ja eigentlich nichts
wo ich bin mit der hälfte
ich habe mal springen ich kann nicht
einspringen
[Musik]
wisst ihr was mich tot ist fakt
ich saß vor gestern
eine stunde 15 hier vorm pc nehme dieses
video auf und checke da meine aufnahme
läuft nicht das ganze was ich an der
hobbit höhle gebaut habe war für die
katz
heute
nehme ich wieder dieses video hier auf
bin genau bei einer stunde 15 und
wertvollem verdammten
braunbären getötet
ich laufe jetzt bestimmt nicht wieder
die viertelstunde von hier
zurück zu mir nach da hinten
ich sitze hier schweißgebadet
leute ist tut mir leid diese hobbit
hülle soll irgendwie nicht sein erst
dann ging es nicht weil meine aufnahmen
nicht aufgenommen hat eineinhalb stunden
lang und jetzt gehts nicht weil dieser
dumme glaube mich an kurt wurden wir
freunde wollen wir nicht fertig jetzt
ein flug war mit seinen scheiß luca
20 da sind 387 stunden später so meine
lieben freunde da sind wir wieder in
unserem dorf stehen hier angekommen hier
vorne links war nicht unser haus stand
er da vorne wir sind ja auch direkt vor
unserem haus gestorben es ist gerade
schon nacht geworden ich kann auch nicht
mehr sprinten weil ich leider kennen
essen habe beziehungsweise keiner hunger
komme oder wie auch immer die kacke
heißt es sind auf jeden fall noch alle
meine sachen hier das freut mich auf
jeden fall schon mal und zum glück gehen
auch in diesen blöden sprüchen die keine
machen
oh mein gott häftling habe ich gesehen
was wir allerdings als erstes erst mal
ganz kurz machen müssen ist dieses bett
hier anscheinend anders hinstellen das
funktioniert dann anscheinend nicht dass
ich darauf irgendwie schlafe wenn da
irgendwie was drüber ist deswegen wenn
ich hierhin stelle steht unten auch zum
ersten mal wirklich wieder
einstiegspunkt gesetzt und ich kriege
auch keinen schaden wenn ich jetzt hier
wirklich auf stehe das allererste was
ich jetzt allerdings erst mal machen
werde dass mir meine komplette rüstung
hier anziehen und diesen blöden bären
töten ich dachte halt wirklich wir
werden freunde sind wir allerdings
anscheinend nicht ich weiß nicht warum
dieser wer mich getötet hat warum er
mich erst angeguckt hat er mir
befreundet aber das ist ja mal ein
richtiger 31 also erstmal das sortieren
die sind schon auf sieben die sachen
brauche ich noch ne idee kommen auf 7
die sache auf der a8 und dann brauche
ich auf der neuen erstmal die birken
holzbretter wir können uns jetzt erst
mal diese blöden bären ich weiß nicht
was eine scheiß mission hier ist mein
gott
wie viel schaden macht
der kommt aber
er kommt nicht durch behält
okay
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich fühle mich ein
bisschen schlecht dass ich diesen bären
getötet hatte ich fand den eigentlich
süß ich weiß ja man sich wehren ihnen
die zähmen kann das weg komplett op so
viel schaden wie machen allerdings
wollte er
wollte ich die heutige folge eigentlich
jetzt gerade schon beenden weil ich
wirklich keinen bock mehr ab hatte
allerdings möchte ich zumindest dass ich
jetzt noch eben zu ende bauen dafür
nehme ich mir jetzt mal ganz kurz neben
meinen
ich bin nicht verplant quatsch wir
nehmen uns hier natürlich unseren
glatten sandstein mal eben kurz raus und
werden den jetzt fordern unsere hobbit
höhle anbringen ich habe euch übrigens
das video nehme ich mich hier wieder so
ein bisschen vorn habe inspirieren
lassen weil dieser hobbit hürde nach
unten in die kommentare gepackt
beziehungsweise in die beschreibung da
könnt ihr gern mal reinschauen wenn das
ganze hier nachbauen volt generell könnt
ihr gerne an die beschreibung schauen
dort findet ihr auch mein instagram da
könnt ihr mir gerne folgen und wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt allerdings
weiter auf diese hobbit würde hier vorne
hier kommt nämlich erstmal eine kleine
laterne drauf damit wir zumindest erst
mal so ein bisschen beleuchtung haben
und laternen werden auch hier und hier
hin gehangen damit generell alles mal so
ein bisschen an fröhlichkeit gewinnt
stuhl ist so unbequeme ich hab ja noch
nicht mal 'ne geile spiele die ich in
hamburg auch hatte damit ihr alles so
ein bisschen an fröhlichkeit gewinnt
habe ich mir auch diese rosensträucher
geholt warum werden
warum haben die anderen farben
das bitte in die kommentare
hier kommt jetzt auf jeden fall so ein
bisschen eichenlaub hin so ein bisschen
um die ecken herum sodass hier vorne
halt alles ein bisschen verbraucher
darauf auch aussieht und hier vorne auch
eichenlaub blabla wenn man das auch hier
vorne so ein bisschen rum setzen und
dann haben wir hier auf jeden fall schon
mal so ein bisschen gemütlicher am
eingang jetzt geht es allerdings darum
dass wir erst mal den weg fertig bauen
dafür mache ich mir hier vorne auch
gerade schon mal drei steine denn aus
diesen drei steinen können wir uns drei
stein knöpfe bauen ich weiß dass sich
der ein oder andere vielleicht fragt
luca wofür brauchst du stein knöpfe
das ist hier schon echt gosee aus
dem kopf ist mein schild
hier da
ach guck mal der schieß den baum an der
idiot
da brauche ich gar kein schild
da habe ich einmal ein schnitt
weggepackt plötzlich trifft er mich oder
was
gehört man zweimal trifft er den baum
hier
und dann wenn ich das schild wegpacken
naja ich habe mal kurz mal so ein paar
süße beeren rein hab ich die denn jetzt
hin gepard durch die egal ich habe hier
vorne auf jeden fall ein paar sprüche
stehen
ich das nächste mal sterbe dann auf
jeden fall ich diese blöden dies wären
sie schon kommen voll zufrieden sagen es
sieht wirklich sehr süß aus wenn man
sich das hier so anguckt die mit dem
häuschen hier mit der kleinen lichtung
generell wenn wir dann überall die hohen
bäume so ein bisschen abfällen
allerdings dann hier so ein bisschen
kleinere bäume hinstellen wie jetzt
glaube ich ganz geil aussehen hier sieht
es doch schon ein bisschen sieht auch
schön aus
der hobbit hülle ich finde es hier
allerdings noch ein bisschen düster aber
das wird alles noch freuen und ich freue
mich wirklich auf den moment wo man
sagen kann das projekt das abgedrehte
man schaut sich diese folge zehn oder
elf sind wir gerade an und denkt sich
nur sowas so sah das damals aus und dann
vielleicht etwas mit folge 50 und sieht
dann so was geht jetzt ab die sache ist
allerdings dass wir uns jetzt auf den
weg konzentrieren dafür benötige ich
nämlich diese materialien hier und das
bruchsteinen hier noch eben jetzt können
alle ein bisschen durcheinander bauen
zum beispiel hier ein bruchstein hin
hier vorne dann einen bemoosten
bruchstein hin dann irgendwie hier
nochmal einen bewussten bruchstein hier
nochmal in den muskel bussteig brüssel
ich brauche das mal kurz ein bisschen so
habe ich den weg hier vorne jetzt auf
jeden fall gebaut hier einfach ein paar
schwein knöpfe hin habe ich mich bei
auch komplett bei selb pixel dann
orientiert weil ich sonst nie
neunköpfigen für den weg benutzt habe
aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz schön
aus wie so ein paar kieselsteine die
herumliegen jetzt gehen wir allerdings
von unserem fast 123 blöcke nach hinten
bauen dem blog abgesetzen wird ein
wassereimer rein und da ich auf java
spiele sieht man nicht dass sie drunter
wasser ist wenn ich einfach eine
fichtenholz waldverein platziere und
jetzt wollen wir alles drumherum so ein
bisschen voll mit unserer hacke heißt es
er glaube ich hier vorne auch und
pflanzen alles voll mit weizen das wird
nachher richtig cool aussehen wenn das
weizen ausgewachsen ist und so richtig
gelb aussieht und jetzt gehen wir hier
vorne in die ecke und setzten hier
besser hin 12 übereinander und zack zack
diese zwei daneben dann können wir hier
auch eine laterne drauf stellen haben
dann hier ein bisschen beleuchtung da
vorne und hier vorne dran und der himmel
ist nicht mehr so beleuchtet
irgendwie vergeht die zeit in diesem
projekt so unfassbar schnell das ist
gefühlt dass siebzigsten mal dass heute
nacht ist ein neuer tag erwartet uns
hier in unserer minecraft welt meine
lieben freunde und jetzt gehen wir von
dieser tal dingsbums nicht so wieder
vorne jetzt 3 block effekt denn hier
haben wir zwei blöcke dran gesetzt
sondern da hier noch einen block steht
geben jetzt eins zwei drei vier blöcke
weit weg bauen den hier wieder ab setzen
dort ein wassereimer reine gehen zu
unseren fichtenholz falltüren setzen da
eine rein und nun wieder ringsherum so
ein bisschen helder hier anbauen zack
zack zack zack zack und hier vorne auch
noch bamm bamm so dass wir dann auch
hier wieder ein bisschen weizen an
pflanzen können wie bereits gesagt das
sieht erst geld aus wenn das nicht gelb
geworden ist was allerdings auch gelbe
ist der übergangs boss unsere
sonnenblumen sind nämlich auch gelb die
läuft bei uns jetzt leider bzw gucken
wir uns in die richtung ist sieht dann
schön auch wenn ich rausgehe wenn ich
allerdings rein gehe hier vorne setzen
auf einer hier zum beispiel noch im
reichen glaubt dann sieht es nicht so
geil aus weil wir uns zeitlich angucken
aber die wachsen halt immer zum
sonnenaufgang hinunter hier halt der
osten ist hier ist der süden hier ist
der westen und der norden schauen sie
halt leider in diese richtung war da die
sonne aufgeht hier vorne setzt jetzt
auch noch mal eichenlaub hin hier noch
eine sonnenblume und hier neben auch
nochmal eichenlaub nun müssen uns
tatsächlich nur noch so ein bisschen um
die margeriten kümmern denn die sollen
hier stehen dann neben dem knopf hier
und hier und hier dann haben wir nämlich
hier vorne auf jeden fall so ein paar
mal gerieten stehen die sind immer so
ein bisschen unterschiedlich aus bin ich
aber auch eigentlich ganz schön und das
hier soll es dann auch für die heutige
episode minecraft mit luca gewesen sei
meine lieben freunde wir haben den
eingang unserer hobbit höhle wir haben
schon vergessen
ich dumme idiot der schornstein muss
natürlich auf unserer höhle draufstehen
deswegen werde ich jetzt generell glaube
ich erst mal alles hier so ein bisschen
schöner machen dass das hier alles ein
bisschen besser ineinander übergeht und
wie ist hier nicht alles irgendwie so
oben offen steht also hier
beispielsweise das alles abbauen das
hier muss stehen bleiben hier oben drauf
aufgrund der sandsteine die ich darunter
gesetzt habe dass es ein bisschen
schöner aussieht hier ist jetzt ein
bisschen blöd mit der diesen höhle die
hier natürlich zum vorschein kommt da
kann ich allerdings mal ganz kurz auf
meine erde nehmen und das provisorische
geht echt weit runter kann ich das
provisorische erst mal so ein bisschen
zumindest zu bauen den ganzen bereich
und dass wir hier halt mich nachher noch
rein fallen also hier einfach alles mal
zu bauen ich werde auch mal diesen baum
hier eben abfällen der stört hier glaube
ich nur und dann werde ich auch den
lockt immer wegnehmen dann schauen uns
das ganze jetzt mal von außen an ob das
einigermaßen natürlich aussieht klar das
muss man auch nie dass ich überhaupt ist
natürlich aus
das muss natürlich allerdings auch alles
noch so ein bisschen weg wachsen hier so
dass künftiges gras drauf kommt und
keine erde dieser baum hier muss glaube
ich auch weichen das kriegt meine art
gerade noch in echt finde diese
modifikation mit diesem trikot war so
geil das spart mir so viel arbeit dann
werde ich das hier fordert auch mal ganz
kurz ein bisschen ausbessern und den
baum hier nehme ich auch noch mal ganz
kurz weg wir müssen generell die bäume
nach und nach alle so ein bisschen
fällen bzw werden natürlich auch ein
paar stehen bleiben wie ich will jetzt
nicht das ganze ding am boden aber
zumindest das ist ja so ein bisschen das
nervt mich auch ne
dass zwischendurch irgendwie ab und zu
so grafikfehler sind das irgendwie
ist da hinten angezeigt wird ist aber
auch egal wir kümmern uns jetzt zu guter
letzt für das heutige video noch einmal
ganz fix eben um den schornstein energie
mehrfach von diesem blog hier eins zwei
drei blöcke hier vorne eben rein und
setzen nun hier vorne dann auch noch
hier und auch hier eine sandstein treppe
da kommen jetzt zwei birken holzbretter
drauf und ein lagerfeuer und wir
verkleiden das lagerfeuer genauso wie
bei unserem start häuschen was wir uns
sehr hier gebaut haben so ein bisschen
hier mit fichtenholz falltüren das
müssen wir jetzt hier natürlich auch
noch so ein bisschen schöner abrunden da
wäre ich denke ich hier generell mal
alles irgendwie so ein bisschen hier in
farbe bringen das ist ja alles ein
bisschen schöner und wunder läuft die
vorne beispielsweise so eine kleine tour
willigen die reihen bringen da hinten
läuft mit klagen dann geht das hier so
rüber und dann haben wir hier auch so
ein bisschen den schornstein nicht hier
um eine kurve rum dann findet sich das
auch eine etage tiefer wieder was ich
hier oben gebaut habe jetzt schauen uns
das ganze mal hier noch eben von vorne
an kann sich auf jeden fall sehen lassen
finde ich sehr sehr sehr sehr geil hier
vorne mit dem schornstein und sieht das
auch alles ein bisschen offener aus die
sonne scheint gerade perfekt rein ich
bin zufrieden meine lieben freunde was
haltet ihr von der hauptschule
beziehungsweise bisher ja erst von dem
eingang der rabbit hole es sieht sehr
sehr schön ausfindig
wenn es dann hier bald noch gewachsen
ist und das ja auch wenn sich das noch
deutlich kleiner aus dann kann man hier
durch so ein bisschen reingucken hier
kann man reingehen und das wird sehr
cool
aber gut wenn euch das heutige video
gefallen hat meine lieben freunde dann
lasst bitte gerne einen daumen hoch oder
dem video abonniert main kanal und
kannst dich auf genug sagen klickt auf
die glocke wenn ihr neue videos nicht
verpassen wollt denn ich sage immer das
video kommt um 18 uhr ihr wissen
allerdings auch ich das selber schneiden
und ich habe auch nebenher noch viel zu
tun deswegen kommen die videos oft erst
um 18 30 19 19 30 also bevor ihr euch da
jeden tag ein bäcker stellt im kalender
da wird einfach die glocke damit kommt
direkt benachrichtungen das video online
geht wir sehen uns morgen wieder um
18.09 episode minecraft lukas dafür zwei
wo ich diese hobbit höhle hoffentlich
fertigbauen werde ich weiß ja nicht
packen werde aber ich versuche sie
[Musik]